N
EMOJI JOE BIDEN.
DO FOR THE PREGNANT MAN EMOJI.
HE IS THE COHOST OF
FOX & FRIENDS WEEKEND HE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
THIS SEEMS LIKE THE KIND OF
ISSUE SINCE THE GOVERNMENT
EFFECTIVELY CONTROLLED THE BABY
FORMULA MARKET WE DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW THAT.
THEY WOULD JUMP ON IT YOU DON'T
TO BE A PRESIDENT WHO IS
PRESIDING OVER A COUNTRY WITH
NONE OF BABY FROM A WISE HICK
KNOWING THIS?
>> IT IS SO INTERESTING BECAUSE
THIS PAST WEEK THE START OF THE
WEEK BY DOING A MONOLOGUE
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
LEFT IS WAGING A WAR ON GOD.
THERE ALSO WAGING A WAR ON
FAMILIES AND IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
THEY'VE DONE EVERYTHING FROM
CRT, INFLATION, ABORTION, GENDER
IDEOLOGY IN YOUR CHILD'S SCHOOL.
EVEN THE CRIME RATE.
ALL OF THIS IS MAKING IT HARDER
FOR YOU TO HAVE AND RAISE A
FAMILY AND SO THIS BABY FORMULA
SITUATION MAY NOT BE
INTENTIONAL, JUST SOME
INCOMPETENCE ON YOUR PART BUT IT
JUST SHOWS YOU THAT THEY JUST
DON'T CARE IT'S NOT A PRIORITY
FOR THEM.
LOOK THEY KNEW, YOU LAID IT OUT
PERFECTLY.
THE FDA TOLD THIS COMPANY, THIS
ABBOTT FIRM THAT MAKES FORMULA,
THAT THEY HAVE TO SHUT DOWN
WHICH IS GOOD IF THERE WAS A
POTENTIAL CONTAMINATION WE WANT
THAT.
THEY KNEW THAT THEY PRODUCE 40%
OF OUR NATION'S FORMULA WHICH BY
THE WAY AGAIN, NOT A VERY
HEALTHY ARRANGEMENT THERE.
THEY KNEW THAT SO THEY BETTER
HAVE A PLAN IF THEY'RE GONNA
SHUT DOWN THE PLANT TO EITHER
GET UP AND GOING QUICKLY,
RESOURCE FORMULA FROM SOME OF
THEIR PLACE BUT THEY DIDN'T DO
THAT.
IT JUST SHOWS THAT THEY JUST
DON'T CARE ABOUT YOU WILL COME
OF AGE ABOUT FAMILIES AND NO
CARE ABOUT MOMS THEY TOLD YOU
THIS PAST WEEK BUT THEY DO CARE
ABOUT.
THIS OF THE NUMBER ONE THING
WHICH BY THE WAY THIS IS BOTH
PARTIES.
THE NUMBER ONE THING WAS A WAR
IN UKRAINE AND LOOK HOW QUICKLY
GOT $40 BILLION OVER THE
UKRAINE.
$40 BILLION, BUT THEY CAN'T
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET FORMULA TO
MOMS AND I TELL YOU WHAT.
TELL A MOM WHO CAN'T FEED A BABY
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT IN
UKRAINE IS THE NUMBER ONE
PROBLEM, YET THERE TO BE ANGRY
AND MOMS ACROSS AMERICA ARE
ANGRY.
TUCKER THEY'RE NOT HOARDING
DOING NETWORKS ACROSS THE
INTERNET TRYING TO BREASTFEED
AND PROVIDE BANKS OF MILK FOR
OTHER MOMS, TO TRY TO HELP EACH
OTHER IT'S FAR FROM THIS UGLY
IMAGE THAT THEY ARE PORTRAYING
OF MOTHERS.
YOU CAN MAYBE FORGIVE JOE BIDEN
WHO PROBABLY HASN'T DEALT WITH
BABY FORMULA IN 60 YEARS FOR NOT
UNDERSTANDING HOW SERIOUS AND
LIFE-SAVING CRISIS IS DECIPHERED
FOR MANY PEOPLE HAD A BABY, A
SMOKE IN ORDER TO SURVIVE TILL
HER LIFE-SAVING HEART SURGERY
BECAUSE SHE COULDN'T NURSE SO
THIS IS SERIOUS BUSINESS.
THIS IS ALSO A SUPPLY-CHAIN
ISSUE HE IS AT THE CENTER OF
THIS AND YOU KNOW HE LOVES TO
TELL US THAT HE HAD THOSE TWINS,
BUT IS MUCH MORE INTERESTED IN
MAKING A POINT ABOUT LGBTQ+
FAMILIES THAN HE IS ABOUT
LOCKING ARMS WITH MOMS RIGHT NOW
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: MAY BE BECAUSE
FAMILIES ARE THE LAST AGAINST
TYRANNY.
IF YOU'VE A STRONG FAMILY YOU
CAN BE PUSHED AROUND.
SO MAYBE THAT ISN'T SO
INTERESTED IN HELPING US HELP
SMALL FAMILIES.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT BUT
AGAIN IT'S ABOUT THEIR
PRIORITIES THEY TALKED ABOUT
FORMULA THAT WAS GOING TO THE
BORDER.
SO I SET HAPPENING?
THAT IS HAPPENING BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO HAVE BAD PRESS
WOMEN COMING OVER THE BORDER WHO
MAY NEED FORMULA BECAUSE ARE
PROBABLY NOT NURSING IN THE
DESERT TO MAKE THAT DANGEROUS
JOURNEY AND WANT BAD PRESS
BECAUSE THEN WHAT THEIR POLICIES
TO END.
THIS POLICY IS IMPORTANT TO THEM
AND THEY'VE DONE EVERYTHING THEY
COULD KEEP IT OKAY SO WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON AND THAT'S
WHY THEY DO THOSE IN MIDDLE THE
NIGHT, THAT'S WHY THEY DIDN'T
WANT IT FLYING OVER THE DEL RIO
BRIDGE.
I GUARANTEE YOU RIGHT NOW TUCKER
THAT THEY ARE SPENDING MUCH MORE
TIME AND RESOURCES TRYING TO
LOCATE THAT BORDER PATROL AGENT,
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO TOOK THAT
PICTURE AND GAVE ITS
REPRESENTATIVES I BET THAT
THEY'RE MORE INTERESTED IN THAT
AND THEY ARE IN THE 14
TERRORISTS WHO CROSS THE DESERT
THAT WE KNOW OF RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT.
>>